à la gare centrale de varsovie
on fait tout ce qu'on peut pour donner
un semblant de vie normale à ses enfants
petits ukrainiens qui ont fui les bombes
et qui ne savent toujours pas où ils
vont finir par se poser comme
l'expliquent kouba un bénévole en
général il reste quelques dizaines
d'heures entre entre 10 12 et une
journée et demie quoi certains semblent
tellement épuisé que ils n'ont pas la
force de
de se lever à 4 heures du matin pour
prendre le train qui va à berlin
certains espèrent trouver un logement
dans la région d'autres attendent un
train vers une autre ville d'europe où
ils ont des proches
on ne veut pas aller vers un autre pays
dit christina qui a fui kiev on veut
rentrer chez nous s'il vous plaît
vladimir poutine arrêtez ce conflit
ici la plupart des réfugiés n'arrive
qu'avec une valise on leur distribue des
sandwichs de l'eau et des produits
sanitaires de first
[Musique]
ou diana qui n'a que 12 ans avait
entendu parler de la première et de la
deuxième guerre mondiale mais elle ne
pensait jamais en vivres
pour accueillir un certain nombre de ces
réfugiés que justin trudeau en visite à
varsovie annonçant 17 millions de
dollars pour accélérer le traitement des
demandes on est en train de faire tout
ce qu'on peut le plus rapidement
possible pour amener le plus grand
nombre de gens possible et c'est
ukrainien s'il cognent aux portes des
ambassades canadiennes se font référé un
site internet du gouvernement pour
remplir une demande
difficile alors de poser des questions
précises les gens devraient pas se
rendre seulement à la mission à varsovie
ou à berlin pour avoir de l'aide pour
avoir leur incapacité d or au canada on
veut qu'ils puissent appliquer de
partout en europe où il se trouve le
président polonais qui a déjà accueilli
dans son pays un million cinq cent mille
ukrainien demande à justin trudeau un
processus simple pour les réfugiés
et où une femme
justin trudeau termine donc avec la
pologne sa visite de quatre pays en
europe un voyage marqué par la
solidarité des promesses mais pas de
développement ou de percée majeure qui
pourrait vraiment changer à court terme
le sort des ukrainiens qui fuient leur
pays si laurence martin radio-canada à
varsovie